cette année tombe en finale face à un
mec allant de Marseille la finale
commence et c'est parti Geronimo il fait
ça Alain de Marseille il fait ça
j'ai remis
Monsieur Alain a gagné bravo quoi ils
vont voir qu'est-ce qui s'est passé bah
c'est très simple j'ai commencé avec la
force il est venu avec la résistance
j'ai fait l'unité il m'a fait la dualité
je l'ai fait la trilogie il m'a fait le
cobra j'ai pas réparer
je ne pouvais rien faire
et non c'est pas fini
vous pouvez nous expliquer ce qui s'est
passé c'est très simple il m'a dit
j'arrive pour te frapper j'ai dit chaton
[ __ ] m'a dit je vais être un doigt
dans le cul moi je tombais deux tu m'as
dit moi je te mets un troisième moi je
te mets jusqu'au coude il me dit il y a
pas la plage ne t'inquiète pas on va
faire la place
[Applaudissements]